e oggi bisogna portare dello stile sul
canale che meno mi contattano i brand di
moda come la ferragni questi saldi
calvin klein si sa mai che mi propongono
robe parte gli scherzi ragazzi allora
buongiorno oggi parliamo di argomento un
po serio sono tornato dal giappone e da
quando sono tornato dal giappone non mi
sentono anche un po troppo a casa quindi
devo rifare l'ambienza fi che sono a
casa adesso questo il monte fuji
intanto sabato l'ho fatta io non è la
loro presa da internet una foto che ho
scattato io questo è andata i ragazzi in
giappone è veramente figo amici miei
oggi parliamo linea roba molto molto
importante e una domanda che mi è stato
fatto ultimamente volevo dare una
risposta anche se non sono tenuto a
farlo voglio comunque farlo mi scuso se
oggi esce un video un po più serio del
solito nel un gameplay
però volevo farlo volevo fare questo
video in modo da togliere completamente
alla domanda e lasciarla solo alla gente
che ha voglia di scrivere cagate perché
fa vj porta four nights perché colui che
si professava l'odiato redi four nights
improvvisamente ha iniziato a fare forno
e io faccio four nights 2 volte la
settimana che non è che sia tantissimo
nella media insomma per chi a chi piace
farne lo segue e mi segue per questo
motivo adesso ma non base al mio canale
solo su quello facciamo anche altra roba
perché mi piace variare però perché ho
iniziato a portare fornell se tempo fa
ho fatto un video questo qui perché odio
fort knight ha reso note di dire la
verità non ci sono stati così tanti
commenti come mi aspettavo di gente che
se ne lamenta cioè nel senso di gente
che mi scrive meno male che odiavi
fornite però comunque volevo rispondere
a questo un sacco di gente che ha visto
appunto questo video ha letto il titolo
il video non l'ha mai visto mai visto e
quindi ha fatto due più due ha detto
felice odia four nights non lo porterà
mai tac fortner cavallo la facevo un
incoerente ma guardatelo questo video vi
prego perché se qualcuno veramente
guarda quel video dall'inizio alla fine
e capisce l'italiano
io non ho mai detto che non avrei mai
portato forte anzi io in un punto del
video dico esattamente questo io non
odio fornet fornite un gioco bello è
bello e luccicante sbrilli e colorato
bellissimo però io non lo fa non lo
faccio perché la gente mi ha rotto
quella roba lì l'avevo che hanno forse
non l'avevo detto che sono stato molto
fieri friendly come bel cerotto questo
riassunto veramente in pochi secondi di
quale di come tutto il video perché io
in tutto il viso ragazzi spiego perché
non porto fornet io non porto non
portavo four nights perché nel pattern
royale non mi divertivo più non mi
divertivo più perché prima non mi piace
costruire per vincere questa è una cosa
che a me non è mai piaciuta quindi io
non me la cavo neanche abbastanza nel
batterio ial non mi piace sparare v non
mi piace il concetto del dattero calcio
e mi piaceva poi mi ha stancato il
secondo motivo che è quello che spiego
per tutto il video è che la gente mi
rompeva le balle per come giocare mi
diceva è il pompa non lo puoi sostituire
fucile d'assalto mi dicevano come dovevo
giocare è capito qui dio in tutto il
video spiego che in realtà io non odio
forte night il gioco ma odio le persone
che mi devono dire come devo giocare a
fornite per questo che me l'hanno fatto
odiare punto questo è quello che dico
per tutto il video che lo spiegano i
minimi dettagli per arrivare a dieci
minuti e monetizzare ora nel video non
mi riconosce in quello nell'altro che
avevo fatto dico anche che four nights
non lo porto se non sporadicamente o
almeno che non si sa come cosa che mi
diverta ed è qui che entra in gioco il
four nights che portò ad esso se
guardate tutte perché voi fate prendete
far niente lo lo mettete in una cerchia
e basta in realtà che esistono due forme
esiste il four nights butter royale che
quello che io non gioco e non giocherò
mai se non tipo con giulia altro giorno
perché ho fatto giocare lei perché
appunto non mi diverte per questi motivi
ed esiste da poco il secondo fornet che
il fort nate in modalità creativa ho
deciso di riportare four tet quando ha
raggiunto questa modalità completamente
nuova e che cos'è questa modalità questa
modalità per chi non lo conoscesse
permette di creare dei mondi e di
giocare i mondi degli altri un po come
happy wheels e di fare cose tipo parkour
e tran escape tutte cose che io facevo
anche in altri vi do anche in minecraft
sempre fatti parkour quando gli hanno
messo guardare detto wow che figata
hanno fatto i percorso ford e quindi
facciamo la modalità creativa che è
completamente è un altro gioco è
un'altra roba non c'entra niente col
batteria oli dato una chance a format
perché mi sta divertendo ed è molto
diverso da prima
se vedete appunto quindi il battere
praticamente quasi mai se non con alcune
eccezioni tipo quella di giulia però
sono veramente eccezioni quel fornet in
un gioco quello nuovo si la nuova
modalità e bella ci sono un sacco di
cose che mi piacciono fare quando l'ho
vista ha detto wow è fighissimo parlavo
i video di stesse fair e che facevano un
sacco di queste cose che volevo fare
anche io ho detto ragazzi vi prego
perciò europa insieme sono bellissime e
abbiamo iniziato a fare loeb e insieme
ad esso non lo faccio sempre con ste
fare lo faccio anche da solo con pietro
insomma ho preso il via anche io sulle
mie creative di foreman perché ormai
grazie a dio ho capito come funziona
tutto adesso fare è tutto molto molto
figo rispetto a prima perché non c'è più
solo al batte royal
amen direi così c'è un po di varietà
perché sono tutti stavano a fare il
batte royal tutti uguali fanno tutti gli
stessi video e vabbè poi aggiungiamoci
anche il fatto che farne ultimamente uno
dei giochi che fa più chiuse quindi sia
perché mi piace sia perché fabius
mettiamo insieme le cose e ben ali
quindi è ovviamente anche per lady ma
non il solo per quello e anche perché mi
diverte fare questa nuova california
fare video che mi portano solo views ma
che non mi divertono non è una cosa che
io faccio punto è una cosa veramente
chiara che deve essere chiara se non
veramente avrei fatto forti anche prima
della creativa
da quando è subentrata la creativa ho
conosciuto anche stesse fair e con i
quali mi diverto un sacco mi continuate
a consigliare mappe nei commenti che io
continuo a fare i video perché cerco di
fare anche quello che piace a voi
ragazzi è diventata è diventata una cosa
molto più di prima ed era questo
che io aspettavo da una vita su fornet
che non ci speravo più invece poi è
successo e niente questa è la risposta
quindi spero di aver chiarito i dubbi io
non ho mai detto che non avrei più
portato formenti ho detto che l'avrei
fatto in modo sporadico
io mi specializza nelle creative poi c'è
gente che si specializza nel battere
rojac sono due cose completamente
diverse
spero di aver chiarito ogni dubbio
ragazzi e gli ultimi video che ho fatto
erano preregistrati da un po perché sono
andato in viaggi in giappone quindi mi
dovevo per registrare un po di video da
oggi mi sto rimettendo a registrare
tutti i prossimi episodi fornet nuovi
non solo di fornet ma anche di tutti gli
altri giochi che sto facendo
ragazzi sto registrando veramente un
sacco di roba fighissime e tra l'altro
non vedo l'ora che esca super meat boy
spero che di aver chiarito i dubbi
ovviamente ci sarà sempre gente fiera
quella frase lì
non aveva visto mai neanche questo video
perché allora non gli frega niente
basta scrivere un commento chissenefrega
mi sorprende però vi giuro perché io
pensavo che da quando ho iniziato a
portarlo o detto l'agente non avrà mai
l'elasticità mentale di capire che è una
cosa diversa la creativa invece mi sono
sorpreso quasi nessuno era negativo su
questa rosa
solo pochi commenti che ho voluto
rispondere anche a quelli per l'ennesima
volta spero che vi sia piaciuto è noi ci
vediamo come sempre nel prossimo video
sempre più fashion sempre più monte fuji
e dovrò nel suo telecomando
iscrivetevi sono stata con i siti e noi
come sempre ci rivediamo anno posso vino
da ragazzi
[Musica]